thinking about
uncertainty as a matter of Primal
importance can actually help
you understand things about the system
that you perhaps didn't understand it
may give you new insights I often think
well when when do you ever go to an
astrologer and he gives you an error bar
on the prediction that you'll meet a
tall dark stranger in two weeks I mean
they don't do that and in a way you
should always take that as a lesson if
you see a a graph of a prediction
without any estimate of uncertainty it's
a good reason to throw the prediction in
the waste paper
[Music]
basket but in a sense um there's
something kind of deeper here and I
think the idea was captured very well by
Richard feineman the great theoretical
physicist of the 20th century who said
our freedom to doubt was born of a
struggle against Authority in the early
days of science it was a very deep and
strong struggle permit us to question to
doubt that's all not to be sure
and then James Glick who wrote a very
well-known biography of feineman um
really encapsulated this sentiment in
one sentence he Fineman believed in the
Primacy of Doubt not as a blemish on our
ability to know but as the essence of
knowing so that's very much where that
phrase Primacy of Doubt comes from from
that kind of quote it's something I came
across quite a few years ago now and
it's kind of been a guiding principle in
many of my uh
work in order to understand the topics
that I want to talk about you have to
understand a little bit of my own
personal biography and sort of apologies
for being a bit self-indulgent in that
area but otherwise none of this will
make
sense so I did my PhD uh back in the
1970s in Oxford in general relativity so
Einstein theory of
gravity and
literally um the first conference I went
went to um I Heard Steven Hawking cuz he
hadn't actually lost his voice then um
give his most famous result of in
science which is that black holes can
evaporate Quantum mechanically they give
off these Quantum
particles and my own
supervisor um guy called Dennis Sharma
who incidentally was also Hawking
supervisor and interestingly if you know
anything about you British Science
Sharma was a student of Paul dur who was
probably after Ein after Newton rather
um not after after Newton he was
probably the most famous and well-known
British
physicist
um so Sharma was really and quite a lot
of the community were very excited by
this result that black holes evaporate
particles and it seemed to combine three
different areas of of physics general
relativity quantum
mechanics and
thermodynamics and then there was a lot
of optimism that the the Holy Grail of
physics which is the unification of
gravity with the other forces of nature
was about to happen this is back in
the uh well actually 1974 there was a
lot of enthusiasm that we were about to
you know this thing that we've been
searching for for years was about to
happen but actually it hasn't happened
and uh if people went to the uh debate
with Roger Penrose and S A hosen Felder
You' see it still hasn't happened we're
still arguing about how to unify forces
and some people string think string
theory is the way forward and people
like Roger and Sabina will tell you no
that's not the
case so why is it and this is sort of
one of the things I I wrestled with at
the time of my PhD why is it that um
unifying quantum mechanics and
relativity is so difficult and I think
my own personal view is it comes down to
the issue about UNC certainty because in
quantum
mechanics you know if you if you know
anything if you read any of these books
you'll see particles can somehow be here
and there at the same time so the
position of a particle is somehow
inherently uncertain according to the
theory philosoph philosophers use the
word
ontological uncertainty to mean this
kind of very basic intrinsic notion of
uncertainty there's something in the
laws of physics and the basic structure
of matter that makes things
ontologically
uncertain on the other hand if you look
at gravitational fields and look at the
equations of general relativity
everything is
perfectly certain and
deterministic it's only if there is
uncertainty it's only because we are
uncertain about the value of the
gravitational field it's our uncertainty
not General relativity's
uncertainty so again philosophers would
call that epistemological un
uncertainty and there's this tension
then between this epistemological
uncertainty on the one hand in gravity
and ontological uncertainty in Quant
quantum
mechanics and my own view is and it kind
of the view I started to evolv
towards in those days and certainly my
view now that this is probably the most
fundamental question in physics is the
nature of uncertainty at the very very
deepest level ontological or
epistemological is it the uncertainty of
nature or is it the fact that we can
never know everything about the world
outside
us anyway these kind of problems um
ultimately made me decide there was no
way I was going to uh make make any
progress it was somehow too
deep and um by chance I I met a a
climatologist Who convinced me this was
a good time to change fields and so I
was in the possibly fortunate possibly
unfortunate position of having two job
offers at the same time one was actually
to work with Hawking in Cambridge to
carry on the kind of Relativity quantum
gravity work and the other was a job a
much more kind of prosaic sounding job
at the Met Office to work on weather and
climate
prediction and I absolutely angst about
this for weeks and weeks and I was like
you know buran's donkey couldn't move to
towards the either the pale of water or
the or the bale of hay just didn't know
I was absolutely Paralyzed by analysis
yeah paralysis by analysis that was me
for several weeks and then I got just so
frustrated by this I decided to hell
with it I'm going to just carry on with
my research for two weeks and then
return to it again for some reason out
of nowhere my subconscious said made the
decision for me and it said go to the
Met Office so that's what I did and I've
had a pretty good career I think but
it's kind of fascinated me and if I have
time at the end I'll come back to it how
do we make decisions under profound
uncertainty it's something that's really
fascinated me and why is it when we
leave it to our subconscious we actually
can seem to make decisions where when we
just analyze things we get paralyzed so
that's an interesting
question now uh some of the older
generation will recognize this guy
Michael fish yeah a folk hero
um he kind of represents a time at the
Met Office where you never really
admitted to uncertainty if you wanted to
make a weather forecast you got on the
TV and you said it will be rainy
tomorrow or it will be sunny or the next
day will be
stormy there was never any doubt or at
least if there was doubt you never
admitted to it you know it would
undermine your professionalism so the
theory went to admit to
uncertainty now I have to say this was
in the I mean the so for those who don't
know Michael fish famously said on an
evening TV weather forecast um well he
said this is what he said earlier on
today apparently a woman rang the BBC
and said she heard there was a hurricane
on the way uh don't if you're watching
don't worry there isn't and there was
and all hell broke loose in Southern
England Seven Oaks lost all of its Oaks
and um damage I think that today would
be in the billions uh was was uh and
people just couldn't understand how
could you know how could you get a
weather forecast so wrong
now one thing uh that people did know
about in the 1980s was the work of Ed
laen and what's called chaos now called
chaos theory and the idea that if you
start two predictions of a chaotic
system from almost but not quite
identical uh starting conditions they
can diverge eventually they'll
completely diverge and
decorrelate now people knew that in the
1970s but the thinking was that the time
scale for these for two weather
forecasts to diverge would be like a
couple of weeks or three weeks the
so-called butterfly effect the flap of a
butter whether butterfly does or doesn't
flap its swings changing the weather it
would take several weeks for that to
happen and in
particular making weather forecast just
a few days ahead should be a pretty
deterministic and um un sort of you know
something you could make with confidence
now one of the very first things I did
at the metopus was starting to look
starting I started to look at these
chaotic models much more
carefully and something very interesting
emerges which is shown in these three
pictures
um this is a this is a Model A very
simple mathematical model devised by
this guy called Ed lent who was a MIT
was a MIT in Boston he was kind of a
half mathematician half meteorologist
and the yellow dots are a fantastically
interesting geometry called a fractal
geometry but what's shown on top of that
are a little initial ring of points so
you imagine inside that initial
ring there's a little bit of uncertainty
about exactly where the starting
condition is let's say it could be
anywhere within that ring then depending
on the where the ring is in this in
terms of this geometry it can either the
top left one shows can hardly hardly
expand at all the ring stays pretty
small or it can start to grow or it can
start to really
explode and the latter one you know can
occur just within a very short time
scale of a few days and I argued that
and this was actually before the 1987
storm that this could happen you know in
a weather forecast we could get
explosive
uncertainty because the degree of chaos
in a system light weather according to
this picture is not something that's the
same every day it varies some days you
can get a lot of predictability and some
days not so how would you actually find
that out ahead of time well the answer
is you'd run not just one weather
forecast every day you'd run a whole
load of weather forecasts you'd run 50
weather forecasts and just look to see
how they
diverged I have to say my colleagues
were very skeptical about this because
they said running 50 almost identical
weather forecasts seems like an awful
waste of computer time we could do
better things with our computers than
running them 50
times but the um the Michael fish storm
really nailed the argument it it was It
was kind of Mother Nature speaking it
did did me a great favor in a sense
because it showed that this really was
um I don't know if there's a pointer or
not but um that bottom one could
actually happen in
reality so you probably can't see this
but this was the original uh what we now
call Ensemble forecast 50 forecasts a
couple of days before Michael Fisher's
storm with almost identical initial
conditions just little flaps of
butterflies differing from one of these
postage stamp maps to the other and then
we move them all forward uh two days and
there's a fantastic spread of possible
solutions so this is telling you this is
hyper we're in a situation where Mother
Nature is hyper sensitive
to uncertainties in the starting
conditions so what can you do with
that well you can combine all those that
information to make
probabilities and that's pretty much
what you know what we do today so in the
case of the Michael fish storm you can
count the number of of those little map
know stamp map things that had hurricane
force
winds um and divide it by the total
number of forecasts that we made which
was 50 uh uh so if we had say 15 out of
50 that would be a 30% probability of
getting a hurricane and that's what this
map shows it's a probability
map
so this has kind of LED it's completely
changed the philosophy of weather
prediction into a much more
probabilistic uh science and you know
one of the consequences of that is that
whenever you look at your weather app
these days and it shows the probability
of rain that's where it comes from they
count you know let's say this is for hey
on
why I got this a couple of days ago I
think for um Saturday so there was you
see there's probabilities of 40% or so
which means that 40% of that Ensemble of
50 forecasts had
rain on hey on
y now you may kind of as I say you may
kind of curse probabilities for being
difficult to use and so on but one area
where they've had a major major uh
impact is in what's called anticipatory
action uh for major severe weather
events so we can use ensembles to look
also at um
hurricanes so these are three examples
of an ensemble forecast the top one is
of a tropical Cyclone that that hit
Bangladesh these are forecasts made
about a week before uh the middle one is
Katrina which is the famous hurricane
that hit New Orleans but a week before
you can see you hardly would know where
on the Gulf Coast or indeed whether it's
going to track up the the coast of
Florida and the bottom one is a is a
hurricane called Nadine where it was
completely and utterly unpredictable a
bit like the three examples in Loren's
model but what happens now is that this
humanitarian agencies actually make use
of these probabilities to decide when to
send in things like medicine and and
food and water and Shel you know
temporary shelters ahead of some
predicted storm you know in the past
it's always been frustrating you've
you've seen on the TV typically these
agencies only act after the event is hit
and you say well why didn't you act
ahead of time and they say well we
haven't got that much money and if we
went in for every hint there might be a
severe storm we'd you know we'd lose all
our funding immediately so what they do
now is they they have a very hard and
fast calculation of a threshold
probability for a a major hurricane or
tropical Cyclone above which they will
then act preemptively it's called that
the whole program is called anticipatory
action and it's really changing the way
in which humanitarian agencies
work so although yeah although
probabilities may be a bit painful if
you like on your weather app they they
really have a they serve an important
purpose uh for for really severe
weather so let me let me move on to um
economics to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit I a.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas